las ciudades son algo más que lugares
físicos y es que las ciudades tienen
vida propia y su éxito depende de que no
sean meramente aglomeraciones de
personas lugares donde simplemente
vivimos o sobrevivimos sino de que sean
lugares vivibles que garanticen el
bienestar de las personas que las habita
moss
sin embargo a lo largo del tiempo hemos
ido viendo como en la ciudad hay
espacios esenciales para la vida en el
barrio que han ido desapareciendo
por ejemplo el comercio local que lo
hemos sustituido por grandes centros
comerciales o las plazas por solares de
asfalto que lo único que tienen de plaza
es la forma o el nombre porque la verdad
me gustaría saber qué pensarían los
antiguos griegos si viesen que sus
ágoras pensadas para ser lugares de
encuentro se han convertido en espacios
como estos
pero hay cosas en la vida que nos hacen
cuestionarnos lo que tenemos y lo que
queremos y un ejemplo de ello ha sido el
commit que nos ha hecho experimentar la
ciudad de manera diferente ya hemos
valorado nuestro entorno más que nunca
que en nuestro barrio podamos acceder a
los servicios básicos
podamos tener lugares para encontrarnos
para comprar para pasear para
divertirnos para descansar
así que la pregunta es cómo queremos que
sea nuestra ciudad en el futuro cómo
vamos a hacer que nuestra ciudad sea un
lugar vivible
durante mucho tiempo la ciudad se ha
construido basándose en el modelo de
ciudad moderna un modelo de ciudad
defendido por robert moses entre otros
señores porque efectivamente
vivimos en ciudades diseñadas
principalmente por señores
robert moses fue el ejecutor el
encargado de los grandes proyectos
urbanísticos de nueva york de principios
del siglo 20 y su filosofía era la de
construir una ciudad a partir de grandes
proyectos de infraestructuras de
rascacielos de vías de comunicación
donde el protagonista era el coche
sin embargo una de las primeras voces
que discutió esta idea de ciudad y
frustró
los proyectos de robert mouses fue la de
una mujer que durante mucho tiempo hemos
ignorado
sobre todo desde el ámbito de la
academia de la planificación urbana pero
que hoy en día está considerada como una
de las figuras más influyentes del
planeamiento urbano contemporáneo si no
la conocéis ya os la presento ella es
jane jacobs
jay jay que fue una activista y una
periodista que nueva york en los años 60
empezó a explicar como ella pensaba que
funcionaban las ciudades
y lo hizo desde el detalle desde lo
cotidiano desde su propia experiencia y
nos propuso la idea de que las ciudades
tienen éxito cuando tienen lo que ya
llamó la vitalidad urbana
una cualidad que tiene los espacios
cuando consideramos que están llenos de
vida que son capaces de aglutinar a
diferentes tipos de personas y
diferentes tipos de actividades
y nos explica que para que se dé esta
vitalidad urbana tienen que cumplirse
distintas condiciones en total 6
la primera de las condiciones es la
concentración
jacobs nos explica que necesitamos que
haya densidad de personas y de viviendas
para que se pueda producir la vida en la
calle la segunda es la diversidad y
tiene que ver con la idea de que las
ciudades tienen que ser mixtas tienen
que aglutinar a diferentes tipos de
personas y de actividades
tenemos que encontrar lugares para ir a
trabajar lugares para ir a comprar
escuelas equipamientos todo esto muy
cerca lo uno del otro
además y como nos dice necesitamos que
tengamos personas diferentes que ocupen
la calle en diferentes momentos del día
y por diferentes propósitos porque esto
nos va a asegurar que nuestros barrios
se vigilen solos porque la constante
presencia de gente y de ojos en la calle
para que los barrios sean seguros
la tercera de las condiciones es la
necesidad de edificios de distintas
características en su momento esto
implicaba conservar los edificios
antiguos y no sólo desde un punto de
vista estético sino porque el hecho de
tener edificios de distintas edades iba
a permitir que personas con distintas
capacidades adquisitivas
pudiesen acceder a la vivienda
la cuarta condición es la oportunidad de
contacto rico nos habla de ciudades que
tienen que estar hechas a escala humana
y esto implica que la medida de los
bloques y de las manzanas no sea
demasiado grande porque esto reduciría
el número de intersecciones de esquinas
y por tanto estaríamos perdiendo la
oportunidad de ubicar diferentes
establecimientos diferentes negocios que
harían que las personas entraremos en
contacto
la quinta condición es la accesibilidad
ya que nos habla de una ciudad que tiene
que estar pensada para desplazarnos con
el medio de transporte que es más
sostenible más barato y más democrático
que son nuestros pies
así que jacobs nos habla de una ciudad
pensada para el peatón no dependiente
del vehículo privado y eso sí con una
gran red de transporte público
y por último nos habla de ciertos
espacios o elementos a los que ella
llama elementos de frontera que son
lugares
que desincentivan esta actividad este
uso efectivo de la calle
por ejemplo grandes vías de comunicación
como vías de tren en superficie
carreteras rondas
también equipamientos algunos
equipamientos de un solo uso grandes
centros comerciales los parques que a
determinadas horas del día nos generan
miedo no son acogedores y que actúan
como un lugar impermeable que no
permiten el paso rápido de un lado al
otro y por tanto son fronteras para la
vitalidad
y estas son las seis condiciones para la
vitalidad urbana que nos explica si hay
cops
y yo cuando lo explico a veces parece
que es un poco abstracto pero lo podemos
medir y precisamente en el grupo de
investigación en el que yo trabajo hemos
hecho un esfuerzo por resumir estas seis
condiciones en un índice de potencial de
vitalidad urbana el indice jane que
hemos aplicado a barcelona a la
conurbación de barcelona que es
barcelona y los municipios de su
alrededor
para ello lo que hemos hecho ha sido
utilizar una malla una cuadrícula
de 100 metros x 100 metros que es más o
menos lo que mide una manzana del
ensanche en la que en cada parcela en
cada celda hemos calculado el valor de
cada una de las condiciones a partir de
variables que hemos obtenido de datos
georreferenciados
estas condiciones las hemos sumado a
partir de una fórmula matemática
y el resultado es un mapa de la ciudad
en que tenemos que podemos ver qué zonas
reúnen las condiciones teóricas para ser
vitales y cuáles no
sybase casillas en blanco es porque sólo
hemos calculado el valor de vitalidad en
aquellas parcelas en aquellas celdas que
se corresponden con lugares donde
tenemos población residente que al final
es donde nos interesa medir la vitalidad
bueno y que nos encontramos aquí lo
primero que nos llama la atención es que
la vitalidad en la conurbación de
barcelona está repartida la encontramos
por diferentes puntos de la geografía
por lo tanto es una vitalidad que sigue
un patrón policéntrico
ésta se manifiesta sobre todo en los
núcleos históricos como el de sants el
de sarria el de gràcia
el de sant andreu entre otros pero
también en municipios de alrededor como
es el caso del centro histórico de
hospitalet el centro histórico de sant
joan despí
el de badalona el de montcada y reixac
también en otros tipos de tramas urbanas
como es la de l'eixample e incluso en
los polígonos de viviendas los
construidos en altura y pongo el ejemplo
de el barrio de san ildelfonso en
cornellá y los construidos en baja
altura como lo que conocemos las casas
baratas que se ubican por ejemplo en el
barrio de can peguera en nou barris
esto es interesante porque nos muestra
que la vitalidad urbana en barcelona no
se concentra sólo en el centro sino que
se reparte también llega a la periferia
por otro lado no nos ha extrañado
encontrarnos lugares con bajo potencial
de vitalidad en los márgenes de la
ciudad cerca de los elementos de
frontera acerca de las rondas de la
consola y también en barrios en lugares
que se caracterizan solamente por ser
residenciales como nos pasan algunas
partes de sant just desvern por ejemplo
pero también y esto sí es curioso nos
encontramos con vacíos de vitalidad o
con lugares con bajo potencial de
vitalidad dentro de la trama urbana por
ejemplo allí donde tenemos vías de tren
o en superficie que atraviesan barrios y
que separan barrios de municipios como
l'hospitalet como en sant adrià del
besòs también en polígonos que aún están
dentro de la ciudad el caso de badalona
montigalà arámbula
también allí donde se han aplicado
proyectos de renovación urbanística
relativamente recientes como es el caso
de el 22 arroba diagonal mar el fórum en
en el frente marítimo de la ciudad o la
plaza europa en avenida gran vía
esto del índice y de los mapas es muy
entretenido y podríamos estar horas
hablando sobre analizando de este mapa
pero para qué nos sirve esto no cuál es
el potencial de un índice de estas
características qué podemos hacer con él
bueno pues nosotros en mi grupo de
investigación decimos que este índice es
una herramienta que puede servir de guía
para las políticas urbanas que tienen
que ir fundamentalmente en dos
direcciones por un lado en los espacios
no vitales tenemos que intentar hacer
los vitales tenemos que intentar tener
los de rojo y los espacios que son
vitales tenemos que pensar cómo vamos a
gestionar su éxito es decir cómo vamos a
hacer que estos barrios no sean
excluyentes como podría estar pasando o
como intuimos que podría estar pasando
en determinadas zonas de la ciudad donde
la vitalidad convive con lógicas de
turística ción de expulsión de los
vecinos de sus barrios y un ejemplo
paradigmático de esto es ciutat vella
y cómo lo hacemos esto como trabajamos
en estas dos direcciones cómo hacemos
que las ciudades sean más vitales
bueno pues tengo una mala noticia y es
que en el planeamiento urbano no existen
fórmulas mágicas no tenemos una vacuna
universal para inyectar vitalidad a
nuestras ciudades
todo lo contrario tenemos territorios
que son diversos y por tanto las
fórmulas las estrategias las recetas
tienen que ser también diversas tenemos
que trabajar con las especificidades de
cada territorio
pero hay una buena noticia y es que
tenemos muchos ejemplos de ciudades que
hoy en día están re visitando y están
traduciendo estas ideas de jim jacobs y
las están llevando al presente a sus
ciudades ya sus políticas tenemos el
ejemplo de parís que quiere ser una
ciudad del cuarto de hora en el que
cualquier persona desde que sale desde
su casa puede acceder o pueda cubrir sus
necesidades básicas en 15 minutos
en esta línea bogotá que está creando
las manzanas del cuidado apostando por
equipamientos que ayuden a simplificar
la vida cotidiana de las personas que
les ayude con sus necesidades de cuidado
diarias
vancouver que quiere ser una ciudad la
más verde del mundo y por eso está
apostando por la economía local por la
economía circular
milan estocolmo ciudades que han
convertido espacios que tradicionalmente
los ocupaba el vehículo privado para
tener ahora espacios de encuentro
y nueva york- un ejemplo de las
muchísimas ciudades que están apostando
por la movilidad ciclista y por el
transporte público
en definitiva muchísimas ciudades
muchísimas iniciativas que lo que
quieren es trabajar para esta vitalidad
para tener ciudades de proximidad
diversas densas y compactas en
definitiva son las ciudades que nos
permiten abordar los retos urbanos que
tenemos y nos permiten hacer ciudades
sostenibles a nivel ambiental social y
en definitiva ciudades hechas para las
personas
y es que no hay que irse tan lejos
muchas veces siempre miramos a los demás
pero no nos miramos a nosotros y es que
barcelona también está remando
últimamente en esta dirección y es que
jugamos además con ventaja porque la
vitalidad urbana es algo subyacente es
algo intrínseco a nuestra propia forma
urbana que es la de la ciudad
mediterránea
y ya hemos visto en el mapa del con el
índice que tenemos muchos escenarios
donde ya se está dando esta vitalidad
urbana
la ciudad es un laboratorio de ensayo y
error y tenemos que utilizar este
laboratorio para entender por qué hay
lugares que tienen éxito y otros
fracasan a la hora de generar esta
vitalidad urbana y esto pasa también por
entender o por acercarnos al
conocimiento a los saberes que tienen
las personas que viven en estos barrios
que muchas veces son las mejores
expertas a la hora de identificar
problemáticas y 20 y de identificar
también lo que funciona del sitio en el
que habitan
así que si volvemos a la pregunta que
nos hemos hecho al principio de cómo
vamos a construir una ciudad vivible
muchas veces cuando pensamos en la
ciudad del futuro nos viene a la cabeza
una imagen como esta
seguramente hollywood tiene algo que ver
con esta imagen mental que nos hacemos
pero a veces para pensar en el futuro
tenemos que volver atrás tenemos que
volver a unas teorías de los años 60 y a
una forma urbana que tenemos que
recuperar
así que el mensaje es claro deberíamos
intentar olvidarnos de estas ciudades de
la ficción que nos obligan a
coches voladores para llegar a cualquier
lado y pensar en una ciudad real en la
que podamos desplazarnos libremente con
nuestros pies
necesitamos que las ciudades del futuro
sean ciudades de proximidad donde la
vida cotidiana esté en el centro de las
estrategias urbanas
necesitamos ciudades vitales porque las
ciudades que quieren tener futuro tienen
que apostar en definitiva por lo que
importa por la vida
[Aplausos]